should a screenwriter start designing
the movie poster before the script is
written no I don't think so I mean I
mentioned that in the writing for the
green light book because that's how we
did it we already had the established
connection and track record of being
able to pre sell movies and to produce
them and deliver them and have them
actually meet the expectations of what
we promise to deliver and we had a whole
marketing department that knew how to
create poster work specifically for the
movie buying audience you can usually
tell when an indie producer has draft of
their own artwork versus when it's done
by you know a company that's used to
selling into the movie space because it
just has a completely different look
it's it's not a marketable punchy pushy
type poster not that there's anything
wrong with it it's just that it's not
the type of stuff that attracts the
buyers from all over the world or you
know things of that nature they get
redesigned and redesigned throughout the
whole process
I think the screenwriter shouldn't worry
about that stuff they're not going to be
in a position especially starting out
where they have to pre sell their
project to buyers they're selling
themselves they're not even selling
their script really they're selling
their talent too right so they shouldn't
have to focus on the marketing
components of creating artwork they
should focus on making sure that they're
you know producing a library of work a
portfolio that they can showcase that's
ideally all of the same type of genre so
they can just be the go-to screen writer
who can deliver that type of film
quickly and reliably just as as I'm
saying we would sell movies pre sell
movies off of the poster people would
pay us and pre buy them because they
knew we could deliver them there's a lot
of companies that try to pre sale that
fail I've worked with ones that were
very successful because we had the track
record of being able to reliably deliver
on time good quality products that's
what the screenwriter wants to do just
from a writing perspective here's a nice
showcase of what I can do this proves a
track record
if you give me the opportunity you can
guarantee and trust that I'm gonna get
it done correctly the first time so why
do you think those other titles failed
what was the reason
did it have nothing David I mean you
said that there were others that tried
the same approach but other companies
especially that look pre-sales is this
really sexy fun idea of like you know I
my idea is gonna be so great I'm just
gonna get 20 countries to jump on board
and buy it you really have to know how
the pre sale process works who the
buyers are at these companies that are
willing to invest that money you have to
you know already have produced a decent
amount of content that's going to kind
of prove the fact that you know what
you're doing and you can deliver movies
on time that are under budget or on
budget that meet all the technicals
specifications of that specific country
you know it's a it's a delicate process
and it's not easy to do and not all
companies do it there's a lot of
companies have no interest in even
trying it but the idea of selling a
movie off of a poster that really only
today happens at the pre sale stage and
not every company does pre sales big
studios that they'll come out and
basically say this is our slate
independent companies we have to go
build those relationships because we
don't have output deals with everybody
we don't have guaranteed buys and you
know the majority of the countries of
the world the way Studios do so those
companies that try to do that have to be
very they have to have a very good
reputation for being able to already
accomplish what they're selling
themselves to be able to do
you